I'm a true follower of Jesus cuz Jesus
was a
Muslim
God God is
God is
God you would be shocked at verses that
clearly mention Jesus being recognized
as a prophet no you wouldn't the Bible
is pretty clear that Jesus is a prophet
Christians believe that Jesus is a
prophet nobody denies that so why in the
world would we be shocked if Jesus is
called a prophet in the Bible it doesn't
make any sense and when he had come into
Jerusalem all the city was moved saying
who is this so the multitude said this
is Jesus the prophet from Nazareth of
Galilee what what they said that Jesus
is the prophet From
Galilee no way look at that verse the
true father of Jesus according to the
Bible when they saw him what did they
recognize him as did they say God no did
they say son of God what did they say
about him well let's actually see let us
let's see what the true followers of
Jesus said about him when they saw him
here's Matthew chap 14 starting at verse
22 it says immediately he made the
disciples get into the boat and go
before him to the other side while he
dismissed the crowds and as we jump down
as as we know the disciples are the ones
that are in the boat right let's see
what happens and those in the boat verse
33 and those in the boat worshiped him
saying truly you are the Son of God
what you mean to tell me that the true
followers of Jesus recognize Jesus as
the Son of God who was worthy of worship
no way let's see what else we find
here's Matthew chap 28: 8 and9 it says
so they departed quickly from the tomb
with fear and great joy and ran to tell
his disciples and behold Jesus met them
and said greetings and they came up and
took hold of his feet and worshiped him
what you mean to tell me that the true
followers followers of Jesus when they
saw Jesus they were excited took hold to
his feet prostrated before him and
worshiped him no not the true followers
of Jesus no way same chapter but we drop
down to the 16th and 17th verse it says
this now the 11 disciples went to
Galilee to the mountain to which Jesus
had directed them and when they saw him
they worshiped him but some doubted wow
incredible there's no way in the world
you mean to tell me that that's in the
Bible that the true followers of Jesus
worshiped him and bowed to him no way
but there are some who doubted let's
check the one who doubted and let's see
what he had to say when he saw Jesus in
John chapter 20 we see doubting Thomas
oh doubting Thomas the follower of Jesus
he says now Thomas one of the 12 called
the twin was not with them when Jesus
came so he didn't see Jesus so the other
disciples said we have seen the Lord but
he said to them unless I see in his
hands the mark of the nails and place my
finger into the mark of the nails and
place my hand into his side I will never
believe so we know who was the one that
was doubting Thomas was one of the ones
that was doubting now eight days later
we see that Jesus appears says peace be
unto you and this is what happens then
he said verse 27 then he said to Thomas
put your finger here and see my hands
and put out your hand and place it into
my side do not disbelieve but believe
now how did Thomas respond when he saw
Jesus and Thomas answered him and said
my Lord and my God in the Greek it's the
Lord of me and the god of me so Thomas
when he sees Jesus he responds to him
and says my Lord and my God he worshiped
him now does Jesus say wait hold on
Thomas slow down you shouldn't be doing
that I'm just a prophet you know the
other verse that you know uthman's going
to use in the future where they say I am
a prophet that's that's it so don't say
none of this stuff don't say this stuff
about me that's Sherk no this is what he
says this is how Jesus responds he says
have you believed because you have seen
me blessed are those who have not seen
and yet believed
so Jesus Praises Thomas for his belief
however he says you believe this because
you see me blessed who believe without
seeing you're supposed to believe that
Jesus is your lord and your God even
without seeing him physically that's how
Jesus responds let's do one more to cap
it off here's Matthew 16 starting at
verse 13 it says now when Jesus came
into the District of cesaria Philippi he
asked his disciples who who do people
say the son of man is now this is
important because umman was using the
verse to say look at what the people
said about Jesus when they saw him so
here's why this is relevant let's see
what the people were saying according to
the disciples they said some say John
the Baptist others say Elijah others say
Jeremiah and or one of the prophets so
they acknowledge that he's that he's a
prophet maybe one of these Major
Prophets that have come by but then
Jesus says but who do you say that I am
talking to his disciples Simon Peter
replied you are the Christ the son of
the Living God wait hold on a second
Peter did did the True Believers
recognize Jesus as the Son of God worthy
to be worshiped while other people
deemed him as maybe just a prophet so if
other people deemed him as just a
prophet but the disciples deemed him as
more than that the Son of God we see
what the true followers
believed Now watch how Jesus responds
and Jesus answered him blessed are you
Simon bar Jonah for flesh and blood has
not revealed this to you but my father
who is in
heaven so right here we see Jesus
affirming that he indeed is the Son of
God and that this Revelation comes by
the father himself it's the father who
reveals the son and it's the son who
reveals the father unfortunately what
uan has just demonstrated is that he has
not had the revelation of the father he
denies that Jesus is the son of God and
therefore is not a true follower of
Jesus so
souma I give you an opportunity man you
can become a true follower of Jesus
today acknowledge him as your lord and
your savior acknowledge him as your lord
and your God acknowledge Him as the
Divine Son of God Who Came In the Flesh
and then and only then will you be a
true follower of Jesus which one are you
there you go right there oh my God logic
oh
[Music]